[Applaudissements]
parmi les partisans de donald trump qui
vous tenté d'envahir le capitole il y
avait des militants du mouvement qua
none mais c'est quoi le mouvement
coislin
ça lui aurait dit bonjour les gars là qu
un homme c'est un phénomène complotistes
apparu à la fin de l'année 2010 cette
hausse états unis dans la mouvance pro
tron séné comment le mouvement qu à nos
aînés avec ce qu'on a appelé le pizza
gates en 2016 à la suite d'un piratage
de mails du parti démocrate toute une
communauté de justicier complotistes pro
trup se sont mis à soupçonner
l'existence d'un vaste trafic sexuel
d'enfants dont la plaque tournante
serait une pizzeria située à washington
il y croit vraiment oui à tel point
qu'un militant qu un homme a fait
irruption dans la fameuse pizzeria avec
un fusil d'assaut pour délivrer les
enfants victimes de ce trafic il y avait
évidemment pas d'enfant et l'individu a
été maîtrisé par la police et ça veut
dire quoi coualan qu 'on s'est formé sur
ku qui est le pseudonyme de quelqu'un
qui sont présentes comme une sorte d'
informateur ministère haut placée dans
l'administration trump et hanon qui
signifie anonymes qui est sa femme qu on
ne sait pas avec une certitude absolue
mais les spécialistes du sujet estime
qu' un faisceau d'indicés très fort qui
pointent en direction de deux hommes
successivement complotistes américain
dénommé paul farmer d'abord et ensuite
ron wood qu'ils renault atkins et le
propriétaire avec son père du site ait
chan où les messages de kew était
diffusé c'est quoi leur théorie leur
théorie c'est que la présence de donald
trump et est sabotée quotidiennement par
une entité appelée l'état profond le dip
state en anglais lequel aurait été
manipulée par une société secrète ap la
kabbale qui se livraient un immense
trafic et de criminel dans lequel
seraient impliqués tout l'establishment
démocrate hillary clinton barack obama
mais aussi george soros par exemple et
qui sont ceux qui y croient environ 15%
des américains croient qu annonce a fait
des millions d'américains très
clairement sont des partisans de donald
trump politiquement très conservateur
plutôt isolationniste en matière de
politique étrangère trois armes à feu
pro peine de mort et anti avortement et
donald ram soutient vraiment ce
mouvement trump a dit qu'il ne
connaissait rien ce mouvement qu un
homme alors que ses propres lieutenants
et lui-même diffuser des contenus
directement liée à la mouvance qui
ânonnent mais aussi une élue
républicaine au congrès margerie taylor
green proche de l'extrême droite
suprématiste blanche qui a apporté son
soutient donald trump en disant qu'elle
y voyait je cite une occasion unique de
sortir de cette cabale mondial de
pédophiles adorateurs de satan
comment ça se propage via des médias
quoi nani si oui c'est arrivé dès 2018
en allemagne et en 2020 en france avec
la création de sites faisant une
référence explicite dans leur titre et
dans leur production à l'imaginaire qu
elle est aidée coualan en france en
france il ya des liens entre les culs
hanon et la mouvance anti vax certains
gilet jaune aussi font parfois partie de
sympathisants mais évidemment il ya de
tout dans les gilets jaunes et comment
expliquer que des gens pensent vraiment
que dp de satanistes gouvernants secret
ça c'est la question qu'on se pose à
chaque fois qu'on est confronté à des
croyances à la fois radicale et
rationnel il ya toujours l'idée que les
puissants les gouvernements cache la
vérité et pour ceux qui croient ça fait
sens comme dans les sectes d'ailleurs on
peut se demander si tu as un homme n'est
pas le début d'un mouvement crypto
religieux sectaires avec ses rites et
ses dogmes un mouvement blanc raciste
xénophobe est au fond très dangereux
[Musique]